one interesting way to explore the
standard model is to look at your uh fun
nuanced disagreement with Carlo
relli when you talked about him writing
in his book electrons don't always exist
they exist when they interact they
materialize in a place when they collide
with something else and you wrote that
well I'll just read the whole thing cuz
it's it's kind of interesting stocks may
not achieve a precise value until
they're ated but that doesn't mean we
can't approximate their worth until they
change hands similarly electrons might
not have definite properties but they do
exist it's true that the electron
doesn't exist as a classical object with
definite position until the position is
measured but something was there which
physicists use a wave function to
describe it's a fascinating Nuance
disagreement so do electrons always
exist or not does does a tree fall in
the Forest if nobody's there to see it
so I like to think of the universe as
being out there whether or not I mean it
would be really weird if the only time
things came into existence was when I
saw them or I measured them there's a
lot of weird stuff I mean I could
believe that the Middle East doesn't
exist because I'm not there now I mean
that would be kind of ridiculous I think
we would all agree on that so I think
there's only so much that we can
attribute to our own powers of seeing so
and the whole system doesn't come into
being because I'm measuring it and so so
what is weird and this isn't even a
disagreement about the standard model
this is an agreement about how you
interpret quantum mechanics I mean I
would say that those way functions are
real I mean one of the things that don't
forget that particle physics does that
Quantum field Theory says is that
electrons can be created and destroyed
it's it's not that every electron has to
be in the universe I mean there can be I
mean that's what happens that collider
is particles get created and destroyed
um but that doesn't mean that if I have
electron in an atom it's not there it's
certainly there and we know about it
it's charges there so physics is a kind
of way to see the
world so what what at the bottom what's
the bottom Turtle like what do you have
a sense that there's a bottom reality
that we're trying to approximate with
physics I think we always have in our
head maybe that we'd like to find that
but I have to I mean I might not seem so
but I think I'm kind of more humble than
a lot of physicists I'm not sure that
we're going to get to that bottom level
but I do think we're going to keep
penetrating different layers and get
further
I just wonder how far away we are you
know we all wonder that um it's not even
like what's even the measure of how far
away we are I mean one way you can
measure it is just by our everyday lives
in terms of our everyday lives we've
measured everything in terms of what
underlies it there's a lot more to see
and so part of it has to do with how far
we think we can go I mean it might be
that the nature of reality changes so
much that even these terms are are
different maybe we'll measure you know
this the notion of itself might break
down at some
point